head off okay the questions from the
Internet's why do you think the
government has decided at this time to
tap into our oil reserves good question
good politics you think absolutely
there's no other reason you don't you
don't do that when oil is going down no
it does not I saw on the news yesterday
what they described as what would be the
criteria for tapping into the oil
reserves it is a national disaster yeah
summer vacations
yeah people getting ready to go away
filling up rest off good politics yeah
yeah can I go back to how expensive oil
is everywhere else but the United States
and now everyone who comes here says gas
is so cheap here right right it's just
one of those things that we complain if
it gets over a certain map oh it's gas
is so high I hate this country
what is it than Europe like two eight
ten bucks now a gallon yeah it will cost
$150 to fill your tank you oh my lord
okay well you know what it's not fair to
people who are on a budget but it's not
fair to the planet to do it otherwise if
you had a gun to your head and had to
vote for a Republican who would it be
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
how big a gun I would get I guess John
Huntsman the one who does the moderate
the moderate you know the one who may I
love that thing he said about the
oncologist it's such a you know of
course he was shouted down for it but I
mean that's the kind of sensible
thinking that I think we used to expect
from Republicans they you have to be if
Obama is so weak as many people have
suggested such a grand opportunity why
are all you know why isn't there a huge
flock of really highly qualified
Republican people well there's nine now
I mean like it was like only a month ago
we were saying where are all the
Republicans and now there's nine
count'em nine who were actually declared
and then my favorites are the four who
aren't in I call them the teasers Palin
Trump Christie and Perry those four I
think would make a much better field
than the nine drones are in there no
news man that would be that that be a
group to cover and true nuts who got
elected right talk about a reality TV
show right seven of the nine can be
nominated never elected Huntsman and
Romney I think are the only two who have
a shot of being elected Pawlenty so we
got a record no Anthony Weiner okay
should we update our Constitution to
include health care as an inherent right
well yeah I don't know why we have to do
everything with the Constitution it just
should be you know it is not supposed to
be a fungible document the again and
again right that that you're gonna pick
it up you're gonna you know it doesn't
usually go well when you alter the
Constitution I mean and you don't have
to you can just make laws you don't know
Matt I don't understand you know they
say Medicare for all I agree with that I
mean when you think about it lots of
people basically have health care in
this country government provided health
care if you're poor if you're a soldier
if you're old if you're disabled just
but everybody else it seems like we're
discriminating against people who aren't
old poor disabled or in the army that
seems like you could actually make a
case that there's a specific group of
people the young healthy civilians who
are not getting what everybody else in
this country is getting they could take
it to the Supreme Court as a classic
yeah the good luck with that is it
appropriate to ask an elected official
if they believe in evolution or is that
none of the public's business well you
know know you and evolution this is
gonna be an all-nighter I thought this
is only a five-minute thing I mean I I
happen to be pissed off about this issue
because they asked the governor of my
home state of New Jersey chris Christie
this question and you know what he said
none of your business none of your
business to a question about evolution
like that's so private that's like it's
what you say when they ask you know did
you make a baby with the maid none of
your really that and he also said
something about how they could teach
creationism in the schools you know I
got a pretty good education in my home
state of New Jersey this just I take
this very personally that this is where
New Jersey is going you know it's okay
if this should happens in Kansas in
Alabama but don't [ __ ] with the smart
states
[Laughter]
[Applause]
to set go
why why are you hacking on Chris
Christie over and over is it because
he's fat or is it public
why are you so down on him because of
what I just said the new - no it's
because of what I just said because I
take it very personally that I got you
know a nice public school education
there and now there is a governor of
that state saying things that I never
imagined a governor of that state would
say maybe it's just false pride that I
think New Jersey is more sophisticated
than this base I think it's if it's
Kansas if it's Missouri no big deal you
know that's the dance low sloping
foreheads the middle places Chris Chris
Christie when you know it's an interview
you have lulled your guests into
revealing them yes chris Christie has
you know I don't agree with this
politics but his ability to execute an
agenda and in Indiana through he's done
a really good job for a big man he plays
well for his you get well first of all
jamming through an agenda there's only a
good quality if it's a good agenda right
George Bush jammed through
agenda also you know I think most
progressives would agree we would love
to have that quality in Obama and a lot
of Democrats the ability to jam through
an agenda and married to good policy
that's what I'm talking about see what
as well.you is he's executing what he
wants to do I'm a reporter so I'm a more
ethical eunuch I don't believe in
anything basically let's keep this guy
talking I don't know what's in that cup
but we got to go thank you very much
folks you were terrific
[Applause]